yeah but of course if you're exposed any
number of us are vulnerable Florida one
of the hardest hit States in Miami one
of the hardest hit cities and we are
joined now by Miami mayor Francis Suarez
mayor good morning you've got this major
outbreak there and you've said it's
partially tied to reopening too soon
right now you're saying to Miamians stay
vigilant might you soon say stay home
you never know you know that's an option
that I have never taken off the table
some would like for us to take it off
the table but it's not an offer you
could take off the table when you have
to look at hospitalization rates weather
or we have to be monitoring the death
rate continually I know our our
hospitals Asian numbers are up they've
been on our new case numbers hit a
record high this weekend Saturday Friday
and the day because the data for
Wednesday so we had we had three days
where we had over 2,000 cases per day
which is four times greater than when we
Institute our lockdown in late March
what is your timetable for making a
decision about a stay at home order and
I asked because a big study came out
showing that if New York had issued its
order just two weeks earlier thousands
of lives may have been saved so every
day that you wait could cost lives
what's your timetable
it's an incredibly delicate balance of
understanding that the stay at home
order is extremely effective we were you
know an increasing about 35 cases a day
before the stay at home order once we
implemented it were able to flatten the
curve and we're decreasing by about 14
cases a day we're now increasing at
least as of last Thursday we're
increasing at a rate of 90 cases per day
so almost three times faster than we
were only how to stay at home or we're
analyzing it every single day in fact at
9:00 I have a I have a call with the
Department of Health which is my usual
9:00 a.m. morning call department vote
and then we make some decisions after
that governor Rhonda Santos in Florida
has said he will not roll back the
opening up of business there in the
state you're prepared to break with him
on that issue yeah I don't look at it as
a political issue or breaking with him
or not breaking with him I think for me
Miami is unique where the densest city
in Florida we were the last one to open
you know I got some criticism for that
but you know from my perspective I'm
looking at the the science I'm looking
at the data I'm consulting with
epidemiologist biostatisticians and also
the Department of Health and then we're
making what we think are the best
decisions for our residents that's how
I've made my decisions I don't I don't
try try to stay away from the national
political landscape or the partisanship
of it because for me this is about like
you said saving lives and making
decisions that are for the benefit of my
residents yeah but of course your
residents hear from you but they also
hear from national political figures and
statewide political figures your
governor has resisted a statewide call
for face masks but one of the decisions
you've made is a mandatory face covering
rule in Miami would you like to see it
statewide I think it should be statewide
I think you know I don't see the
downside in making a mandatory statewide
to me it's no different than forcing
people to oversee both you know when you
were a seat book it's it's a
precautionary measure you know you're
not guaranteed to live when there's a
car accident but you have a much much
higher chance and so when you're wearing
face masks all the studies I've seen
demonstrate that you know the face mask
will reduce the chance of getting the
chronic virus by about 85% so you know
for me it's sort of a no-brainer so then
the question becomes should it be
federal as well we heard the president
this weekend say 99% of coronavirus
cases in his view are quote totally
harmless does that line up with what
you're seeing in Miami no that doesn't
line up 99 percent or not totally
harmless and I think there are a
percentage I maybe even a large
percentage that are asymptomatic or very
very little symptoms or don't require
hospitalization that's you know that's
that's a very high percentage but that
99 percent are not you know problematic
or are not dangerous I wouldn't go that
far I think unfortunately we're seeing
more and more people be hospitalized
younger people be hospitalized we lost a
very you know very young person very
young boy this week only also lost a 40
year old
this week so I think you know we have to
be very very careful we have to monitor
this very closely every single day all
right we'll continue to do it as well
mayor Francis Suarez of Miami thank you
very much rooting for you and for all of
Florida